random guy walking by about to see psy
there's a white Malcolm just walk right
by coward no Doug decides as the Marquis
it's like okay stand by that stick here
it was how bad your stick memory is it
was right there yes that stick folks
somewhere in there and I turned the
sticks into an arrow so you can't miss
it
bad acting no no bad stick look I can't
work like this
this were really the shining you would
have berated her into a nervous
breakdown
oh come on you're just wasting
everybody's time you know that Richard
just made everybody's time rise that's
just like well those two really short
lines it's because she's paying too much
attention to where her mark is it's just
so confusing
where's our mark these things God I've
been actually using this bush well now
you're knocking it down
how is she supposed to find her mark
action I'm professional I'm not laughing
okay hey the soldier critic random white
person I figured out what the miniseries
do better than the movie if you took the
stick as a marquis remember the line
better
hey nostalgia critic random white person
I figured out what the miniseries a
better than the movie god this is so
hard
hey miss soldier critic random white
person I figured out what the can we cut
to you doing a turn you and Malcolm so
that way we're not going to that was
very Kubrick and sam raimi because Bruce
can do a sword fight
looking like samurai no hey missed Alger
critic random white person I figured out
something the miniseries did better than
the movie Jack's character let me do one
more I she's on the wrong side of the
screen
what really yeah I was like cuz I was
aiming I was aiming for the lead
should I do a turn to that the cameraman
agrees with them like seriously guys hey
critic we felt kind of a bad abandoning
you in the middle of things
Delta bad huh
you look like Jay Cutler postgame when
he's doing like the press interviews is
you know it was hard doing it with this
mallet but a lot of people say it was
Gracie maybe I am but you know it's a
different game it's different guy I'm
like to thank Jesus Jesus my mom
actually Cutler thanking Jesus wouldn't
happen because he is Jesus according to
himself so I like to think myself I
couldn't down without me I think I'm
appreciated as movie crossovers go I
mean wasn't good per se it wasn't really
Avengers the but it was still pretty
decent I just walked in one place right
now no point in continuing Wow
I'm gonna be explaining this at the
pearly white gates I hope at this point
they were all out of that color turns
out all the disciples are black and I'm
sitting there now you don't know that
your honor
yeah we should fry film Rachel spits
that sounds bad - I'm not use the word
bits anymore no it sounds bad we're
gonna fill Malcolm's parts no it's I
forget them Malcolm there is no way I
cannot make this sound but we're gonna
film Malcolm as a white guy there that
sounds ok everyone can agree with that
the old white woman down there it's too
white he's not even gonna catch on the
camera I know it's like he's like
glowing white this my god Jim and I were
just having a great conversation about
this James Patterson novel - check it
out even more articulation though even
more to talk very white
okay okay fuck you Doug that was really
no no no no no no no it is over the time
okay you know how Hugh Laurie is very
obviously British and he's trying to
fake the American accent by talking very
slowly all right this wouldn't be
offensive so I'm just going to I'm just
mesmerized it's like you're nervous you
know like kind of I know curly-haired
white guy before you mean have I ever
seen the ghost of Harpo Marx no this is
a new experience for me Lucille Ball we
can do a whole routine so Wow King
actually did something better than
Kubrick fresh basil for schnitzel